So what we're going
to do today is
continue our discussion of
modular computer software,
and specifically
focus on the topic
we started talking about last
time called soft modularity.
And once we figure out,
you know, finish our story
with regard to soft
modularity and understand
exactly what this
means, we're going
to start talking about a
different kind of modularity
called enforced modularity.
And enforced modularity
is going to actually
take us through three lectures,
today and the next two lectures
next week.
And the topic for today
in terms of enforced
modularity is a particular
way of obtaining modularity
in computer systems called
client/service organization.
Some people call it
client/server computing.
And that's the plan for today.
So what we saw the last time was
basically a lecture describing,
for the most part,
how linking worked.
And the idea in
linking is that when
you have a number
of software modules,
and your goal is
to take all of them
and get an executable
program out
of them that another program
could load into memory and run.
And that task was
being done by a piece
of system software
called a linker,
and out pops an
executable program.
So at the end of the lecture
last time, a couple of students
asked me two things.
One was why we were
actually talking about this.
And the second more
important question
was why it wasn't in the notes.
And so let me answer the first
question [SOUND OFF/THEN ON]
question first.
The plan in lectures is to
understand concepts of computer
systems with examples.
And oftentimes we
find examples that
aren't actually in the notes.
And we use them,
A, because if we
don't use different
examples, there's
sort of not as much
incentive to show up.
But often because some of
the examples that work better
in lecture don't actually work
out as clearly in the notes.
So we do tend to use
different examples.
To answer the first
question, why we actually
looked at the
linker, first of all
it's a common piece of software
that pretty much every program
that you run today goes
through a process of linking.
But what it actually
allowed us to do
was illustrate two
main concepts in naming
having to do with the way
in which the main mapping
algorithm worked.
And in the context
of the linker,
the problem was to
take these symbols
that you find in the program,
and basically resolve them,
in other words, find out
where they are defined,
and where the instructions
corresponding to those symbols,
or where the data
corresponding to the symbol
was actually located.
And the concepts that we saw
were two different concepts.
The first was name mapping
using a table lookup, where
within each object file
there was a symbol table that
mapped between the
symbols found in a module
to the location where the
symbols were defined further.
And another example of
doing name mapping, which
was the process of search
through a series of contexts.
And in particular, we
looked at the problem
of when you are in the context
of LD, which GCC uses when
it finds, goes through
a sequence of dot O
files as well as
libraries on the command
line, what algorithm it actually
uses to resolve its symbols.
And I realize now that what
I had left out on the board,
there was a couple of
mistakes in the algorithm,
and I asked what mistakes were.
And I realized I didn't show
you what the actual algorithm is
correctly.
So I thought I'd spend
a minute doing that
so that if you have something
wrong in your notes,
you can fix that up, because
I actually never said
what the right thing was.
So if you recall,
the general problem
was you have GCC running
on a set of dot O files,
F1 dot O all the way
through Fn dot O.
And what we're trying to do
is describe an algorithm where
when you obtain the I'th
object file and you have a set
of currently defined symbols,
and a set of currently
undefined symbols, how you
can maintain three sets:
the set of object files
that go into the executable,
the set of defined symbols
that have been seen so far,
and the set of undefined symbols
that have been seen so far.
And you want to
keep updating that.
So one way to easily see what's
going on is with a picture.
So up until now, until you've
finished I minus one files,
let's say you've built
up a set, U, of all
of the undefined symbols that
have been encountered so far.
And likewise, you have another
set, D, of all the symbols
that have been defined so
far that you've encountered
and have been defined so far.
So, D and U dynamically
change as you
go from left to right through
the sequence of files.
Now, when you are
on the I'th file,
there is a set of symbols that
have been defined that are
going to be defined
in the I'th file.
And that set does not
intersect with a set, D,
because if it did, then you have
an overlapping defined symbol
and that's an error.
So the interesting case is to
look at this kind of an example
where you have a set, Di, of
the symbols that were defined
in the I'th file.
And likewise, in the I'th file,
there are going to be a set
of undefined symbols.
And clearly, that set doesn't
overlap with a set, Di,
because if it's
undefined, it can't
be defined in the same file.
So that said, in general,
looks something like this.
It has some symbols undefined
in this object file that
are also undefined previously.
Some symbols that are
undefined in this file that
have been defined previously,
and some symbols that
have been undefined here
that you've have really
never seen before.
So you've got to
update to things.
So D gets updated pretty easily.
D just becomes D union Di.
And if D intersection
Di is not null,
then you know there's an error.
And now you need to update
U, and there are many ways
to do it that are more
efficient than what
we're going to write out.
But it's pretty
easy to see that U
needs to get updated by unioning
the current set with Ui.
So that kind of gives you
this together with that.
But now, you have to
subtract out everything
that's been defined already.
And since we updated D first,
we could do that very easily
by just subtracting out the
set of all defined symbols.
And you run this
through until the end.
And if you find that in
the end U is not null,
then you know that there's
an undefined symbol
so that the linking
doesn't actually work.
You can produce an executable
out of it with static linking,
OK?
OK, so when you do combined
programs in this fashion
to produce an executable, there
are all these different modules
that have been brought together
to run in an interpreter.
And you have to ask,
what kind of properties
that program ends up having.
What kind of modularity do you
get by combining these modules
together in this fashion?
It will turn out
that modularity is,
it's a form of modularity
called soft modularity.
And to understand why,
you have to understand
what the interfaces between the
different modules look like.
Basically when you
look at a C program,
and you saw an example last
time of how these modules hook
together, the different
modules track with one another
through procedures.
And procedures
between modules have
something that I'll call
a procedure contract.
And really, to understand the
property of the modularity
that you get from
procedural contract,
we need to understand
a little bit
about what happens
underneath the callers
when a caller of a
procedure invokes
a callee of a procedure.
And this is actually
material from 004.
So if you have forgotten,
I'll refresh your memory
a little bit about it.
So, very abstractly, if
you look at a computer,
it's got a processor in it that
actually executes instructions,
and it has a chunk of memory.
And in that memory, there
is a portion of memory
that corresponds to the
stack which is really
where procedures,
the interesting stuff
with procedures
gets implemented.
And you also have a
bunch of registers,
so, inside the processor.
And you have a
special variable here
called the stack
pointer, which keeps
track of where the
current head of the stack
is that you can then start
pulling elements off.
The general plan, the
caller and the callee
interact with one another
by means of the stack.
So when a caller wants to
invoke the callee, what it does
is it takes arguments
of the procedure,
and pushes them on to the
stack one after another.
Then the last thing it
does is to tell the callee
where it should return control
after the procedure function
has actually been executed.
And that's the last thing that
pushed on top of the stack
is the [NOISE OBSCURES].
So then, after it does that, the
caller then jumps to a location
where the callee's
module is located,
and then control
passes to the callee.
What the callee then
does is it finds out
what the return address
is, pops the arguments
one after the other, and
then goes ahead and runs
the function.
And then at the end of that,
it looks at the return address
and passes control back.
And before it does that, it
actually puts the answer.
Let's assume that it puts the
answer in a special register.
And that's part of
the contract as well.
And once the caller gets the
control back from the callee,
it can proceed as before.
Now, the important
thing about this way
of interacting between caller
and callee with procedure stack
is this contract has to obey an
invariant or discipline called
the stack discipline.
And the essence of
the stack discipline
is that the callee should
leave the stack exactly
the way the caller left it when
it invoked the callee, which
means the caller had set up
a bunch of arguments on it,
and it but the
return address on it.
The callee should
leave things as is.
And in fact, the callee is
not allowed to touch anything.
It should leave everything
as is this pretty
much except for the register
that has the answer.
And as long as this
discipline is maintained,
and that invariant is maintained
across procedure implications,
this model of using stacks
is extremely powerful.
You could implement all sorts
of procedures, nested procedure,
I mean, recursive procedure,
mutually recursive procedures
and so on because each of these
implications of the procedure
has a certain portion of
the stack that corresponds
to an activation frame.
And as long as this
discipline is maintained,
you can do quite complicated
and interesting combinations
of modules.
But the problem is that that
modularity depends crucially
on the stack discipline
being maintained.
And any violation of
[SOUND  OFF/THEN ON] callee
can disrupt the caller
and bring it down.
And there are many ways
in which this discipline
could be violated.
And the easiest
one is that there
is some error or
bug in the callee,
and the callee
corrupts the stack.
Or the callee corrupts
the stack pointer,
so it actually
[SOUND OFF/THEN  ON] control,
but the stack pointer
points somewhere else
and some bad instruction
runs, or you have a problem.
Now, another problem is
that the callee crashes.
For instance, there
is a divide by zero,
or there is some
other violation that
causes the callee to crash.
And then the caller comes
crashing down as well.
And there's a bunch of other
reasons, but all of them
have to do with the stack
discipline being violated,
or with the callee
crashing and control never
returning to the
caller, which means
that the caller and
the callee share fate.
If something bad happens to
the person who has called,
sorry, the callee, then the
caller struggles as well
and isn't able to continue.
So colloquially this is
referred to as fate sharing.
And the resulting
modularity is soft
because any fault or error in
the callee affects the caller.
The caller, there isn't
any kind of a firewall
where errors in the
callee are insulated
from errors in the caller.
There's no shielding between
the caller and callee.
And, where is this thing going?
Like, all right, so
there's no insulation
between caller and callee.
And the resulting
modularity is not as hard
as we would like it to be.
So this is the problem
we'd like to solve today.
And the first solution
we're going to discuss
is a way of organizing
callers and callees
into an organization called
client service organization.
And the main idea is
going to actually involve
a different abstraction by which
callers and callees communicate
with one another
from the abstractions
we've seen already.
We've already seen
the memory abstraction
where you could write
values to a name,
and another person
could read from it.
And we've already seen the
interpreter abstraction.
It could turn out we are going
to use a different abstraction
A location path abstraction to
implement the client service
organization.
And the idea is the following.
The program is going
to be decomposed
into clients and services.
And you might have many
clients and many services,
and you could have
a client which
is a client of one service
and service in turn
is a client of yet another
service and complicated things
like that.
But any pair-wise
interaction is going
to be between a
client and a service.
And think of mapping
that example onto here.
Think of the callee, for
example, being the service
and the caller being the client.
The caller wants some work
done, so it's the client.
And it invokes the service, the
callee, to get that work done.
And the plan is going to be
that the client and the service
are going to run on different
computers, physically
different computers,
and we are going
to connect the
computers up with wire.
And the idea is the moment you
do that, the crash of a callee
doesn't actually bring
the caller coming down
because it's running on a
completely different processor.
The stack is not shared.
The memory is not shared.
The stack point is not shared.
There's really no problem with
regard to the callee crashing,
bringing the caller down.
Of course, we now need a
way by which the client can
communicate its
arguments to the service,
and the service can
communicate its arguments back
to the client.
Previously, we
did the first one.
The arguments were communicated
by putting them using memory
on the stack, and the answers
were coming back to us
from register.
And we don't have that
shared state anymore.
So, we're going to have to
implement that using messages.
And we're going to
take these messages,
use the communication
path abstraction,
and send messages from
the client to the service.
So imagine that time flows
downwards starting from when
the client invokes the service.
A message is sent
from the client
as a message to the
service saying here's
all the arguments, and
here's the procedure
that I want you to run.
And it takes that information
up, somehow packages it up
into a message, and calls send.
OK, and the assumption is
that the client somehow
already knows something
about the name of the service
or the location of the service.
That's outside of the scope
of the current discussion.
Let's pretend somebody
tells you that here's
where the service
is running that can
run this function for you.
So it takes the arguments in
the name of the procedure,
packages it up the message,
and send it across.
When the service
gets the message.
It validates the message to make
sure that it's the right sizes,
and it's not too big, and so on.
And then, it takes this message
and then does some processing
on that message.
The technical term
for it is going
to be called
un-marshalling because when
we took these arguments
and put into a message,
that process is
called marshalling.
The service is going to
un-marshall this message
and obtain the actual arguments
and the name of the procedure,
and then it's going to run it.
I don't know if it's
one L or two L's.
And then it's going to run the
procedure that's named here.
And it's going to
find the answer.
And then when it
gets the answer,
it does the same thing back.
It puts it back into the
message and sends it across
to the client.
And now the client is
waiting for this message
because it sends off the
message to the service
to run this thing.
It gets this answer back.
It does the same thing.
It takes the message in that
it recovers the answer from it,
and then it runs continuously.
So this is the basic idea in
client/server organization.
And the way in which
we solve this problem
is that these two problems are
solved because the callee can't
really corrupt the
stack or the stack point
or anything else
that in this model
would have affected the caller.
And because we have put
them both on physically
different computers and
hooked them up with,
let's say, a wire, the service
crashing does not actually
bring the client, if the
service decides that it crashes,
then the client actually
doesn't come crashing down.
Of course, the
client has to somehow
have a plan by which it knows
that the service is still,
for example, the
client has to know
whether the service has crashed
or whether the service is just
taking a long time
to run something.
That's something we have to
address, and we will in a bit.
But as long as the client
is able to do that,
a service going away or
crashing is not really
going to bring the caller
or the client down with it.
So, some properties
of this organization
are, first of all,
that it's modular.
It has essentially
the same modularity
as we had with
procedures because if you
had enough computers,
you could move
all of the different procedures
on different computers, all
of the caller/callee
relationships,
and you can preserve,
essentially,
the same modularity
that you had before.
Moreover, this modularity
has a different adjective
in front of it
different from soft.
This modularity is enforced.
What that means
is not only is it
a modular organization, it's one
where errors of, for example,
things where one
module fails or crashes
does not bring the other
one come crashing down.
So the modularity
is more enforced
than when they were both running
on the same computer using
the procedure interface.
And the third property of
this kind of modularity
is something already mentioned.
It lies on the message
abstraction, actually
the communication
path abstraction.
The client and service
communicate with each other
through messages.
And these aren't
actually messages.
You can't just sort of take
a random string of bytes
and send it to the service.
It's actually messages
that correspond
to a particular format.
And these are really
known in advance.
So, that way the
service isn't surprised
and the client
isn't surprised when
messages that don't conform
to that pattern arrive.
I mean, you know exactly
what kind of message
is going to arrive.
And anything that
doesn't conform
to what is agreed upon
in advance is rejected.
But you basically make
it so that you explicitly
declare the nature of
these messages much
like you did the nature
of procedural interface.
But now, because you've
physically separated it,
you have a more
enforced modularity
than in the previous model.
Of course, nothing
comes for free.
It's not like you got
this enforced modularity,
and you have all of these nice
properties that you did before.
Here, you had a nice
property that the callee
could, has the property
that either when
it runs and it returns to you,
you know exactly what happened.
And if it doesn't return,
you know that you usually
come crashing down.
If the callee doesn't return,
it means that control never
comes back to the caller.
So it's not like
the caller is left
wondering what really happened
because the caller doesn't
get control again.
Here, you have a problem.
If the callee, the service
doesn't return back
to the client, the
client actually
doesn't know what's going on.
When you have two machines, two
computers connected over a wire
or over a network,
it's extremely hard
to distinguish between a service
running really, really slow,
and a service that's gone away.
And we'll revisit this a few
different times in the course.
But it's going to be impossible
for us to tell for sure,
although we're going
to try very hard.
It's going to be really
hard for us to tell for sure
whether something
exactly happened.
And if the service
didn't return,
we don't really know for sure
without much more machinery
whether it was just that the
service is still running,
or whether it's crashed,
and we are just waiting.
And so, this organization
requires a timer at the client,
and there are many names
given to this timer.
I mean, people call
them keep-alives,
or people call them
with various names.
I'm going to call it a
watchdog timer, where
the client has to
keep track using
some kind of a timer
of the service.
And if the service doesn't
return within a certain period
of time, the client has
to time out and say,
well, the service didn't
return, and I'm not
quite sure what happened.
It might be that the procedure
I wanted to execute had ran,
but I didn't get the answer.
Or it might be that
the procedure didn't
get executed at all, and
I have to deal with it.
And you might be able to,
by retrying the procedure,
or you might contact
another service which
provides the same
functionality, but the client
has to deal with all of that.
So fundamental to this
client's organization
is the notion of a time out.
And we didn't have
that here because here,
if the callee decides that
it's just going to continue on
and not return, the caller
never gets a message back.
So, it doesn't have
this decision to make.
There is no such
notion of a watchdog
that we have to worry about
in this other organization.
So another nice property of
this client service organization
is that so far
we've presented it
in the context of the
client and the service
being modularized
from each other,
and we've enforced modularity
to the client and the service.
But in fact, there is
another nice property to it,
which is that a client
service organization allows
us to design modules and design
systems where clients get
modularized from each other.
We can achieve soft modularity
by protecting clients
from each other.
The idea here is that if you
have many clients all of which
want to use a given service,
for example, there's
a service that's, let's
say, implemented by a bank
and what it does is
it's the service that
deals with managing
your accounts,
and you can move money
between accounts,
and it will tell you your
account balance and so on.
You can implement
that as one service,
and many, many clients can
share the same service.
Now, all of the clients trust
the service because, I mean,
if you are a customer of a bank,
and you are using your browser
to look for your account
balance, that means
you sort of trust the bank.
And all the clients
trust the service.
But the clients sure
don't trust each other.
And the nice thing
about this organization
is that you can use the service
in the form of an intermediary
that allows the clients to be
separated from each other, each
of which can use the service.
But the clients don't
have to trust each other,
and clients don't
really have to know
about each other's information.
And this idea of using a
service to modularize clients
from each other is called
a trusted intermediary.
There is many examples
of trusted intermediaries
that we'll see in this course.
In fact, tomorrow's recitation
on the X Windows system
has a system where
your computer screen
is going to be managed by a
service called by the X Windows
system.
And there are many clients that
are going to use that service.
And the clients don't
actually trust each other.
They want to get modularized
away from each other.
And the X Windows system
as a trusted intermediary
deals with that.
It managed this resource
-- your display,
and it arranges for the clients
to be designed each independent
from the other.
And in general, we are going to
see in the next few lectures,
many examples of the operating
system being a trusted
intermediary, arranging
for many different clients
to use some resource on your
computer like the processor
or the memory or the disk.
And our architecture
for the operating
is going to end up being in
the form of these trusted
intermediaries.
So, so far we've seen what
client service organization
means.
It means you have a
client and the service,
and they communicate
with messages
using the communication
path abstraction
of send and receive.
And we've seen some properties
of client service organization.
But I haven't
actually told you how
to implement any of this stuff.
And so that's what we're
going to do the rest of today.
And in fact, we are
going to continue
with different ways
of implementing
various forms of client service
many times in the course.
So there are many ways to
implement client service
organization.
And all of them have
to do with, all of them
involved different ways
in which messages are sent
between client and service.
A common way, and a
pretty standard way,
of implementing it is something
called a remote procedure call.
There are many examples
of remote procedure
called systems.
I mean, one of the
most common ones
is something called the
Sun Remote Procedure Call
system, or Sun RPC.
That's one example.
There are many other
examples as well.
A more modern example which
some of you may have heard of
is a relatively new system,
about five years old,
called XML RPC.
So if you've heard of
buzzwords like Web services
in business-to-business
interactions,
or business-to-business
applications,
these things use
something called XML RPC.
And, there is a lot of different
three letter acronyms and four
letter acronyms.
This has led to
something called SOAP,
which stands for the Simple
Object Access Protocol.
So there are many different ways
of implementing RPC systems.
And until last year
or a couple of years
ago, we used to
talk about Sun RPC
as an example in this class.
But I decided that's
so 20th century.
So we're going to talk
about XML RPC today.
It has a property that's
much more inefficient,
but that's sort of
keeping with the fact
that computers
have become faster.
We don't have to worry in
many cases about efficiency.
So we are going to talk a little
bit about how XML RPC works.
So let me first show you
what a client written what
this kind of RPC looks like.
It's going to show
you a code snippet.
All right, I had to work hard to
make sure it would fit on this.
OK, all right, the
way this thing works
is actually very, very simple.
This uses something called XML
RPC Library for Java that was
written by the Apache people.
And once you incorporate
that library,
your program becomes
completely easy.
So let me just walk
you through this.
The high level idea
here is that it's
transferring money from
one account to the other
through a service
that's run by the bank.
So, the first line
of this thing here
creates an XML RPC object,
an XML RPC client object.
And what you give it is actually
the name of the service.
So somebody has to tell you
And I don't want to get into
the details of everything here,
but the basic idea
is your backname.com
colon 8080 is the name, the DNS
name at which the service runs
and the port.
The thing about
XML RPC is that it
runs over HTTP which
is what you use
to transfer objects on the Web.
And underneath, we talk
about how it's implemented;
underneath this is implemented
using a standard method in HTTP
called a POST which
allows, normally
HTTP has a GET
where you retrieve
But it also has a
POST that many of you
are familiar with
where the client can
push some stuff to the server.
And it just uses POST method.
What's going on is very easy?
You create a vector
of parameters,
and you fill that
vector in with,
in this case, your
account number.
And let's say here the
idea is this sort of thing
is very popular in big
companies like Ford or Cisco,
which have thousands
of suppliers.
And, they never
actually maintain a lot
of inventory of their own.
They're always trying
to figure out the latest
cost of any of their supplies.
And they are using this
Web service like interface.
In fact, this is also called
a Web service interface
to communicate with
their suppliers
to always have the latest info
whether their suppliers have
any given item in stock, and
how much it costs and so on.
So, let's pretend you have
done that in your company,
and you are trying
to pay off, you
are taking your
suppliers' account number
and pay some money to him, OK?
So in this case, whatever,
dollars is that argument.
So you create parameters.
And all you do at the end is
you use these XML RPC client
objects, and invoke a method it
presents to you called execute.
And you give it two arguments.
The second argument
is the parameters.
And the first argument is
the name of the procedure
that you wish to
run on the service.
OK, that's in this case
called MoneyTransfer.
So, corresponding to
this, somewhat longer
is a piece of code running on
the service which implements
the server side of it,
which basically obtains
[SOUND OFF/THEN ON] calls an
object that will un-marshall
the arguments, and then it
will execute money transfer,
both of which [SOUND There
is very little that actually
has to run on the service.
It's just a little
bit longer than this.
Now, this line
here is important.
That's the line on which
you get your result.
And this gives the
result as a string.
If I tell you that I
finished transferring
X dollars from this account to
that account, or if I tell you
I couldn't transfer, and there
was some kind of an error,
or you might actually not
get any answer, in which case
the underlying library that
implements this procedure call
would throw an exception
your code has to deal with.
And how you deal with it is
a little tricky because you
don't, and you'll
see this in a moment,
you don't quite
know what happened
when you didn't
get an answer back
from the You don't know if
this actually got your transfer
request and crashed after that.
And, it got the request.
It actually implemented the
transfer and then crashed.
It just couldn't send
your response back.
So, you're not quite
sure whether you need
to retry the request or not.
You will actually
see how to deal
with this in a few minutes.
Now, there's one
thing that's really
important about
this line of code.
This xmlrpc.execute(
"MoneyTransfer") block,
that line of code actually
is not something that runs
on the service.
OK, it's a local procedure.
xmlprc.execute() is
a local procedure.
OK, and that procedure is an
example of something called
a stub because what it is,
is a stub that to this caller
fakes out the fact that there's
a service somewhere else.
I mean, it prevents
the caller from having
to deal with 15 arguments
and putting it in the message
and sending it to
the other side.
The caller just calls
it over the procedure,
giving it suitable arguments
that pinch for this
function now to do
the work of sending
a message across the network.
But this is a local call.
So, what happens underneath?
Underneath in the library,
once you call xmlrpc.execute()
in this example,
somebody does work.
That library does the work of
taking the different arguments
that have been presented
to it and converting them
into a message, marshalling all
of the stuff into a message,
and then shipping that
message off to the server.
That has to be going to some
kind of a format on the Fly,
right?
Ultimately on this wire
connecting the client
to the service, there's format.
And I already mentioned that
this runs on top of HTTP.
And so we can actually look
at what that looks like.
OK, so POST here is the
method that you use in HTTP.
The /RPC2 is actually the same
thing that was used in, if you
remember in the
previous screenshot,
when we did the new call to
get a new XML RPC client,
we gave it a server
name and a port number.
But we also gave it
something called RPC2.
Now, that's just like a
file on the other side.
It says there are many
different RPC programs running
on your service.
And I want RPC2 to run.
I mean, I could have named
it anything I wanted.
And that's a lot like
giving a file name on a URL.
And then, you go on.
You give it the host name.
This is a lot like
an HTTP header.
The interesting new stuff
here is in the XML arguments.
But those were not
familiar with XML.
It's just a method,
a way of sending
things that have attributes and
values associated with them.
So, every method has
the format that it's
attributes and
values, and they can
be nested within each other.
The only interesting
thing that's here,
this particular XML RPC system
supports a few different data
formats.
You can do integers, and
characters, and strings,
and doubles, and floats, and a
few different things like that.
And I thought it just means
that the 32 bit integer,
and you can take numbers that
sum up your account number,
your supplier's account
number, and the amount of money
that you want to transfer.
The good thing is
that all this stuff
has gone underneath the
covers, and you don't actually
have to deal with it if
you are writing the client
or you are writing the service.
All this work
happens underneath.
So, it greatly simplifies
your ability to take,
implement client
service programs
with clients and services being
separated from one another.
OK.
So, so far, we've
made it look a lot
except for this little timer
that you have to maintain.
We've made it look a lot
like a remote procedure call,
it's like a procedure call.
In fact, the code here,
the only difference
is you replace
what was previously
what would have been one
big transfer with arguments
we replace with a
stub call, taking
the name of the
procedure we want
to run on the service
[NOISE  OBSCURES].
So, it looks a lot
like a procedure call.
That actually is a
pretty deceptive thing.
And in fact, a
hint at that is you
can get at the bottom
of this thing up there,
there is a light
that says you have
to deal with XML RPC exception.
And that's the kind of exception
you get when the underlying RPC
library decides
that it hasn't heard
an answer from the service in a
while, it throws an exception.
And your code has
to deal with it.
You are never going to
get that kind of exception
from a regular procedure call.
I didn't hear back
from the caller
or from the callee
to do something.
See, that's a new exception
mode that you didn't previously
have to deal with.
I mean, you have to deal with
other kinds of exceptions
but not this one.
So, an RPC is not the
same as a procedure call.
And in fact, it's a
little unfortunate
that, for historical reasons, we
are stuck a little bit with a remote
procedure call.
In fact, increasingly
more and more RPC systems
don't look like
procedure calls at all
in terms of the semantics.
But we were so
stuck with the name
that people continue to have
various kinds of remote procedure
calls, and they used
the same name for it.
And the first main difference
arises from the fact
that there is no fate sharing
between client and service.
If the service crashes,
the client doesn't crash.
Already you have
a big difference
between a regular
procedure call.
And previously I presented
this as an advantage
because if you have
fate sharing, then
this caller is always at
the mercy of the callee.
But because you have
no fate sharing,
you have other
problems to deal with.
And in particular, all of
these stem from the fact
that it's extremely hard to
distinguish between a failure
versus extremely slow.
And it will turn out
that we revisit this
over and over again.
We'll talk about networks
and reliable transmission
over networks and
deal with it, and then
we're going to talk
about fall tolerance,
and we're going to talk about
an idea for atomicity,
and then we're going to
talk about something called
transactions.
And they're all going to
deal with this problem
that it's going to be
very hard for us to tell,
when you ask somebody
to do a piece of work,
whether they did it
fully or did nothing.
OK, and this is going
to be a repeated theme,
a theme that is going
to repeat in the course.
But to complicate
why this is hard,
let me say three
possible things that
could happen when you have
a client talk to service
and what kind of semantics you
want from a client They all
stem from the fact that this
is extremely hard to determine.
The first semantics
that you might want
is the idea semantic.
The client talks to the service,
and either the service answers
with a response or it doesn't.
OK, and that's something
called exactly-once semantics.
So in this example here,
underneath the library,
it may time out.
And it may wish to retransmit.
Or it may wish to throw an
exception at the caller.
The client may want
to send this again.
But in an ideal case,
you want exactly
once this amount of money
to be moved from bank
account one to bank
account two, right?
You certainly don't want
your amount of money
to be moved twice
to your supplier.
The term of this
is ideal, and it's
going to be pretty difficult,
and extremely hard,
to achieve
exactly-once semantics.
And, we're going to talk
about different methods
in the course.
This is not an easy
problem at all.
It stems from the fact that
it is very hard to know.
So, you might give
up a little bit
and say, OK, I can't really
get exactly-once semantics
very easily.
But let me try
for at least once.
So what this means is the
client will keep retrying or the
the library will keep retrying.
And you can decompose
it in either way
until it is sure that this
call succeeded at least once.
Now, it might have
succeeded more than once
because the service
is very slow.
And then it times out.
You try it again, the service
says, oh, OK, I see it;
I must not do it again.
But, it's at least once, OK?
Now, at least once
is not nice semantics
that you're using at least
one semantics in your code
here, right, because your
supplier might end up with $7
million instead of $1 million.
But at least once
is OK if the service
has some kind of semantic
called idem-potent semantics.
What that means is that when you
do an operation more than once,
the answers are the
same as at-least-once.
A simple example of this
was the transfer of money,
but you checking
your bank account
It doesn't really matter that
you do it a hundred times.
As long as one of them succeeds
and you get your bank balance,
you are fine.
I mean, doing it seven
times does not really
change anything; it does not
move extra money anywhere else.
So that's an example of
an idem-potent action,
which works out well with
at-least-once semantics.
And at-least-once
semantics is much easier
to obtain than
exactly-once semantics.
And the third kind of semantics
is something converse:
most-once semantics.
That means zero or more times.
And here, the
challenge is really
figuring out if it really
worked at least once around.
I mean, I pushed once or not.
So, if you don't get a response
back, then you time out.
And it might be that it
didn't succeed at all.
And you say that's fine.
I'll deal with it separately.
And if you get a response back,
then you know that it worked.
It turns out, even that is
going to be a little bit
tricky to implement.
But these kinds of
semantics you could
expect from your RPC system.
Now, actually the first R in
most RPC systems like XML RPC
don't really deal with any
of this in a particular,
I mean, they don't
really provide
any well-defined semantics.
It's usually for the
client sitting on top,
and the service is
still, they don't
know what kind of
semantics they need,
and implement that at
a higher layer at least
with most of these
standard protocols.
But many of them
are well equipped
to deal with
at-least-once semantics.
OK, and through
the course, there
are different ways
in which we'll
accomplish these
different goals,
these different semantics that
we want from our different RPC
systems.
Now, there's another difference
between regular procedure calls
and remote procedure
calls, or more
generally from client service.
Remember in the
second lecture, I
told you that you can
always get more bandwidth,
and you can always get more
processing past Moore's law,
but one thing you
can't actually change
is the legacy between
two computers connected
by a wire connected
by a network.
The speed of light
doesn't change.
What that means
is that with time,
the number of constructions
that you can run,
when you have two computers
separated by a wire,
there is a certain delay between
that no matter what you do.
So there is a certain delay that
you do a procedure call that's
a remote procedure call.
It takes a certain
delay to send a message
and to get a response back.
Even as computers get faster
and faster and faster,
that isn't changing at all.
But the problem is that
the number of instructions
you can run but
within that duration
is increasing with time because
it's a fixed amount of time,
and the number of instructions
you could run locally
on the computer
increases with time.
So that has led people to be
more aggressive about what they
do in a remote procedure call.
What people said is, wait,
it doesn't make sense
for a client to issue
a procedure call,
relocate to a
service, and then just
sit and wait like in a regular
procedure call, for the answer.
I mean, I'm just sitting
there twiddling my thumbs,
and this thing is that way, and
I'm waiting for it to respond.
I could be doing work.
So, that's led people to
changing the synchronous model
of RPC, of a procedure
call interface
to do something called
asynchronous procedure call
interface.
And all the things like
XML RPC and its follow-on,
and the difference
between SOAP and XML RPC
is that I can understand this,
and this builds on XML RPC.
It seems like very few
people understand SOAP.
There is a lot of
people who have given up
on trying to understand
the specification.
But XML RPC turns out to be a
really simple seven or ten page
document that's very
easy to understand.
A lot of people use it.
But anyway, all these systems
support asynchronous RPC.
The idea here is
that the client sends
a procedure call indicating a
remote request to the service.
And then it goes
about doing its work.
When the service
responds with an answer,
it responds with not
just the answer, but also
something that tells
the client which
service request, which
procedure caller request
it's responding to.
And when the response comes
back, the client can handle it.
Now, the way in which you
have to implement this,
or the way you
have to design this
is that associated with
every procedure call request,
you also have to
associate what's
called a handler
because you're going
to issue this request
to the service
and then go about
doing your work.
When the answer comes back,
the RPC library underneath,
the communication library has
to know: who gets this answer?
Because you might have to a
sheet of many such service
requests.
So who gets this answer?
So you associate
with every request
a callback, a handler,
which then is called back.
And that handler runs,
dealing with the answer that
comes back.
And so, that actually allows you
to be a little more decoupled
than we were with the remote
procedure call; even more
decoupled.
The client services
are even more decoupled
because the client is no
longer waiting for the service
to return an answer to.
So that's the first way which
people have extended it.
The second way in which
people have extended
is using this intermediary
idea that we talked about
before where the services
cross the intermediary.
To use this intermediary
idea to actually make
design remote message based
communication systems where
the client and service
don't actually have to be up
and running at the same time.
So actually, the client
could send a request out
to the service.
But the service is actually
not up and running.
So, the idea is there
is an intermediary that
acts as a broker on
behalf of the service,
and buffers the message.
And then, when the
service comes up,
the service knows to pull the
message from this intermediary.
That's buffered
messages, correct?
And then it processes the message,
and then pushes the answer
back to the
intermediary, which then
stores the message to some
other intermediary perhaps.
And then the client
knows to get the answer
from that intermediary.
So now, we can actually
have clients and services
that interact with each
other without actually
having to be up and
running at the same time.
There are many examples
of this, and the notes
talk about various examples
of intermediary communication.
So the general summary of
what we've talked about so far
is that we looked at different
ways of attaining modularity,
talked about soft
modularity last time,
and today about a particular way
of enforcing modularity using
client service organization.
And the next few
lectures, we are
going to solve a big weakness
of the current system which
is that you need many
different computers.
So we are going to
take these ideas,
and implement them
all on one computer.
See you next week Tuesday.